[Music]
this
is star talk neil degrasse tyson here
your personal astrophysicist
and for this edition it's cosmic queries
which we are titling
the cicadas are coming attack of the six
i don't know what we're going to title
it but it's about
cicadas nagina that you laughing my
co-host nagin farsad welcome back
to star talk nagin hi neil so great to
be here
excellent you're a host of the podcast
fake the nation
which i was a guest on that one time i
so enjoyed that and you haven't invited
me back ever since
i enjoyed it apparently you didn't all
right just so you know
you wrote a book that has my favorite
title of any book ever
it's called how to make white people
laugh that's just
[Laughter]
that's just out of control girl what do
you what do you
so this is advice for people of color to
make white people is that what that is
um it turns out neil throughout writing
the book i found out that what makes
white people laugh is what makes
everybody laugh
there it is it has a kumbaya message to
it
okay but there's it doesn't land on but
there's a lot of it's kumbaya with a lot
of fart jokes let's just put it back
okay
so uh i'm pretty sure you don't have
expertise in this and i definitely don't
um in just insects in general are such a
fascinating uh part of the tree of life
and i have a new colleague at the
american museum of natural history
been there just barely a year and it's
dr jessica ware jessica welcome to star
talk thanks for having me on the show
yeah so you're an evolutionary biologist
so that's sort of your base
uh landscape on which you then have
become an entomologist
so why don't we just call you a
bugologist what's what's
what is the latin root there that it's
saying that you study bugs well i've
actually been called a bugology i've
been called an
insectologist before but um entomologist
is
you know the study of all insects
because not all
bugs um not all insects are bugs all
bugs and insects but
not all insects are bugs it's one of
those things so you know class and
sector has
many orders and only one of the orders
well wait wait excuse me
if it bugs me i'm calling it a book okay
don't tell me
that something hurts classy people i'm
not
happy people call bugs bugs and insects
insects so if you want to
impress people in your life in your
personal life then you say
oh well actually and people will think
that you're very classy
because you know the distinction between
the other orders
i promise you it's a hit it is a
palpable hit at a party
oh oh jessica you live in such a weird
world
if that's the distinction between people
thinking you're
classy or not no she runs around saying
there are two kinds of people in the
world
so you're a tenured curator of
invertebrate zoology at the american
museum of natural history right here
in new york city so your a fellow
scientist of mine
is delighted to have you in the house um
now your research
of course it focuses on insects you have
a specialty
in dragonflies woohoo
you know nobody doesn't love just
looking at a dragonfly we'll get to
cicadas in a moment
but just how did you grow up thinking i
want to study dragonflies is that how
that happened
uh well no definitely not i didn't know
that people did that for a job in fact i
didn't know that entomology was a job
really
i thought maybe i would go and work at a
bank or something like that when i got
a job and my nana would say what do you
want and i'd say a cab driver because
you get to meet
people um and she was mortified uh but
no i went to
university for marine biology um and
then when i started taking invertebrate
zoology classes it turns out almost all
of the class is insects because
almost all life on earth are insects uh
and so then that's when i got kind of
turned on to entomology
um and then i was really lucky that i
got to work on the coolest of all of the
insects which are the dragonflies
it is definitely the cool it's uh let me
not say it's cool let me just say
it's badass that and it knows it right
there it is it's got those wings and
it's got that needle shape
and it flies and then it just stops and
let me look around for a minute and then
it just keeps it
and it's like what are you thinking dude
like lions in the sky really i mean
they're like voracious predators
they can do intercept you know predation
where they can
you know go to where their prey is going
to be in 10 seconds
rather than like a dummy going where the
prey is right now
i mean like a lion would do and i mean
that's that's pretty impressive
oh okay so if you come back can we do a
whole show on just
dragonflies because i've seen fossil
remains of dragonflies
that look like birds and i want to get
to the bottom of that why did they get
little how did they get big in the first
place
so if you come back for that because i i
because we have
i really want to get straight to the
cicadas all right
let's go straight to the cicadas you are
insect person
in the house so what's
about to happen not to the world perhaps
but just into the
northeast united states in this year
2021 don't we have enough problems
jessica well i mean this is the solution
this is not the problem this is the
solution to having a bad year
is that there's these periodical cicadas
that are coming out to bring us some
enthusiasm so bring us some pep to our
day
we have these bruises says the bug
person
says the bug person this would be a nice
time
for for the bug people and the cicadas
okay
just let's let's okay
the gift that we get the response the
positive pep for 2021
is that we have this brood route 10 uh
which is comprised of three different
species
of cicadas that are going to emerge and
we'll get to hear them and see them
we'll get to eat them if we want to i
mean this year is going to be pretty rad
just because of the fact that we have
these periodical cicadas
that are going to be emerging um it's
kind of remarkable i was saying if this
is a gift i
i really don't want to know what you get
people for christmas
just like go ahead and take me off the
list
[Laughter]
when i think of periodicals i think of
something that's daily or weekly or
monthly or even
annually such is not the case with
these cicadas so what's going on there
how long what do you mean by periodic
when you
use that word with them so these
periodical cicadas are called that
because they actually
um have a juvenile stage in an adult
stage
and the juvenile stage lives underground
for either 13 years or 17 years
and they emerge as adults periodically
every 17 years or every 13 years like
a pretty bad newspaper subscription if
it was every 17 years
i would argue yes correct unless just
reporting on continental drift
right
[Laughter]
that was a solid joke neil thank you for
laughing at that one nicki
i enjoyed it good
um so so which species is coming out
this season is it the 13 year or the
17th year
we have 17-year uh cicadas that are
coming out
um and there's three different species
uh in this in this one genus uh that are
going to be coming up
that makes up this brood brood 10
because the periodical cicadas are
enabled
different broods but they were just
named by these you know these guys in
the 1800s
they were kind of documenting what was
going on and they gave roman numerals to
the different kind of emergences
of these you know cicadas and so route
10 kind of is
you know an arbitrary name in some ways
uh uh
it doesn't necessarily mean that nine is
next door or
11 is next door if you know what i mean
well so this brood is not
the the cycling of them it's not like
the last time they came out
it was brood 9. no yeah so the numbers
um don't necessarily
make immediate sense um when you look at
the years when they came out of where
they came
i love that [ __ ] when a scientist says
this won't make immediate sense to you
it's like that's very honest i'd love
that
yeah he's on a 17-year cycle what what
is that how is that not reasonable
complete sense yeah um and so these
why aren't there also uh predators
of these of these cicadas that would
come out
in that 17-year cycle and eat them they
they're very high in protein i
understand
well i mean there are predators that eat
them um so
i mean that's the the set the strategy
we think is that they're doing kind of
like association strategy
where they come out in this giant you
know
emergence and the birds and frogs and
your dogs and your cats and humans and
you know lots of things are going to be
feasting on them and hopefully everybody
around you gets eaten
and you don't and you can find a mate
reproduce
um and then die uh that's kind of the
association strategy
that we think natural selection has
acted on you know over over millions of
years
um uh uh we think that these people
yeah but jessica if that's the best you
can hope for i just hope i'm not
eaten this is what kind of a life is
that
well i mean i think that's probably what
most insects are thinking
uh not that they actually think um but
if i was to anthropomorphize an insect i
would imagine
you know they have these jobs to do as
an adult right they have to find a mate
they have to disperse
uh they have to lay their eggs and then
they die and if
a bird or you know a fish or a frog uh
jumps up and catches you uh
your your net fitness is zero if you're
dead this is isn't survival of the
fitness yeah that's what you're doing
fitness yeah now now you describe these
as a as a
as a genus is that right um this
okay so genus um uh just remind me so we
are homo sapiens
so for us the of those two words the
homo is the genus
and the sapiens is the species so in
this
genus of of of cicadas
you have species beneath that correct in
the
taxonomy yeah i always remember it king
philip came over for good sandwiches
for the kind of taxon you know the
classification
kingdom
[Music]
uh king philip came to order
the sandwiches and then use the same
word that somebody someone clever should
get in there and fix that
kingdom phylum
cicadas this is so weird i'm watching
two of the smartest people in the world
figure out this order right now okay
wait wait wait wait wait so kingdom
phylum
uh order uh or
a class ordered genus species yes these
are all good scrabble words i would
argue
wow okay all right good on it
i'll be an entomologist yet okay
and i'll start liking them so we're
spinning through that for the record
okay so uh nakeen we've got uh cosmic
queries from our patreon
members so what what do you have let's
start i don't want to spoil their fun
let's start with violetta this is
violeta 12 and a half year old
astrophysic kid and mega star talk
and mega nagin fan i like to start off
the show with a compliment to me
um but her question is how are cicada
such amazing
time keepers what kind of hocus pocus is
this and what can it teach us about the
concept of time itself
and how we measure and study time
ourselves
yeah jessica it's sorcery clearly
they're they're like
witches and warlocks for for cicadas
what's going on down there
um yeah i mean that is is an interesting
that's a very good question via lettuce
so
kudos for that um definitely i think
that i mean the timing of when they
emerge they're using temperature as a
queue
so when the ground reaches 64 degrees
fahrenheit then they know that it's time
to emerge
but they have these kind of regimented
um
moltings so let's take a step back so
there are
two types of insects villeta there's
insects that have complete metamorphosis
which are things like you know an egg
that becomes a caterpillar then there's
a pupa and then there's the butterfly
that butterfly has gone undergone a
complete and total
internal reorganization before emerging
as a butterfly
those insects are called holometabola
and they're the insects that have
complete metamorphosis
the other insects are the non-hola
metabolism
these are insects that have incomplete
metamorphosis of which cicadas are one
so they instead have juveniles that
usually look a lot
like the adults they don't look like the
adults in cicadas but
usually they look very similar to the
adults like just a small grasshopper
this is a small grasshopper that gets
slightly larger as it goes through these
molds molts is it molting is a period
where
they actually shed their skin um and
then go to a large what's called a
larger
instar which are the stages of
development so
cicadas when they're underground the
juveniles they actually
you know when the egg hatches the first
instar actually drops down into the soil
and kind of nestles down into their
little pocket where they're going to
start feeding on the plant roots
but then every certain amount of time
then they go through a mulch and then
there's another long period of time
and then they go through a mold and
these are kind of like jumping ahead in
their growth stages
and so the timing of those instars are
kind of really
really precise and they're based on like
there's a hormonal cascade
that kind of uh controls the timing of
those those instars
and then after the last one when the
temperature reaches 64 it's go
time and then they crawl up and go time
go time and then it's
you know their wings uh and the adult
winged uh
cicada is what you see look look at her
smiling as she describes the invasion
she's totally getting into this oh my
gosh this is creepy
so if the ground has to be 65 degrees
that means
we will see the cicada invasion as they
rise up and become our overlords this
will happen at southern latitudes
sooner than in northern latitudes we
have to presume here is that correct
yeah absolutely so at 64 64 degrees is a
pretty
you know um magic number and some
individuals you know it's the timing is
pretty great
right but when you're talking about 17
years you know
some might come out a couple days early
some might come out a couple of days
late
because there's going to be millions of
them emerge so we got to cut them some
slack a little bit with their clock
no i guess what i'm asking so if we're
going to see this invasion
in the northeast united states as i
understand it they'll show up in like
virginia
first and then because the the the the
more southerly latitudes will reach
those temperatures before
maine will or before new hampshire will
isn't that cool absolutely
yeah okay okay all right [ __ ] give me
another question um
and also just are they friendly like is
this gonna be a good hang
or like i grew up in the desert so we
didn't have this like
what happens like is it gonna be cute
and fun are we going out to brunch with
the cicadas or is it just like awful i
don't know
uh yeah i definitely would say it's a
good hang i mean you want a concert you
got it
because they're gonna be singing and
they're gonna be making noise um
you want to eat brunch they're brunch
right i mean they they are going to be
on the menu so uh they're friendly in
that they
are plant feeders they feed on on xylem
when they're when they're juveniles
but as adults they're really focused
xylem would be like what
xylem is what like the the juices or the
plant juices inside of the
the tree uh the sap okay interesting
you guys got a word for that that's cool
asylum it's pretty cool it's his x-word
which is another good scrabble one if
you if you
love x-words yeah um but i mean we will
not play scrabble with you
we would just establish that i'm talking
of a big game but i'm actually
terrible at scrabble but it's enthusiasm
that counts i think rather than
than success um
but yeah so they they emerge they're
really their goal
is to find a mate to lay those eggs and
then they die
so they're they don't have a lot they're
here for a good time
not a long time right so they're just
gonna do their business
and then they did and we just gotta wait
for the eggs
sweep them out man now gain we we uh we
got to go to the next segment
um so uh but you have you've got more
questions lined up we're gonna find out
how many questions
yeah we got so many uh we're gonna find
out what kind of
damage the cicadas will actually do to
us will they
um destroy civilization as we know it
and we'll not give you the answer to
that until we return
star talk cosmic queries
we're back star talk cosmic queries
attack of the cicadas
i've got one of the world's experts on
insects and who's
all knowing about cicadas here a friend
and colleague of mine from the american
museum of natural history
dr jessica ware jessica welcome to star
talk
and of course uh nagin farsad um it's
always great having you here is my
co-host and you got questions for
jessica bring him on yes okay so woody
asks
what are the positive consequences of a
locust plague
feeding the birds is one thing but is it
an essential part of the ecosystem
how do you think the changing climate
will affect insect plagues in the near
and far future wow yeah and are you even
calling this a plague
jessica i mean it sounds very biblical
you know the frogs the locusts
the cicadas so uh
you you see no downside to this it seems
like because you spent this entire
interview
smiling ear to ear i wouldn't call it a
plague i mean
the the beauty of it yes they're great
bird food but they're food for
lots of different things lots of mammals
and other other organisms
and then i've talked i've said many
times they die
right and as they die all of the they
decompose and all that nutrition goes
into the soil
the very trees they were sucking on you
know sometimes
uh for that 17-year period so you know
nutrition uh for the for the trees
uh and for the the kind of spill
community um
as well as food for for animals i mean
that seems like a pretty good win
i mentioned i like song the song is the
music for us that's another plus
they're beautiful they're pretty what
you like earrings you could have
earrings in spades because those
uh cicada wings make really nice
earrings um
i mean i can't i can okay now you're
getting creepy wait jessica stop
stop
jessica is off the rails ladies and
gentlemen
jessica you got to get out more jessica
we need to do an intervention
in the game we'll do an intervention the
silence of the lamb's movie poster
suddenly you know yeah
i mean the entomologist in that movie
seemed a bit intense
i might not be you know really
increasing the red level of
entomologists of this interview
but they are pretty they're pretty come
on give me that
all right okay so let me ask this they
don't eat our crops or anything
and disrupt our food chain they do not
um
so uh we really don't need to in that
way they're not locusts because locusts
that eat your crops
you can justifiably call that a plague a
blight on your
on your on your own ecosystem okay so
they're harmless is what you're saying
they're harmless and i mean they've been
doing this for a week from what
researchers seem to estimate around 500
000 years so they've been doing this
long before we were here um
and they'll continue to do this chris
simon the university of connecticut has
done
a lot of work on this particular group
of cicadas
and i mean maybe for around four million
years or so there have been cicadas
because there are annual cicadas that
come out every year
but then around 500 000 years ago there
was a switch to
being having this periodical uh genera
you know genus and species um and then
like
the first nations native people that
lived uh in this part of new jersey the
lenape they had a separate word for the
annual cicadas
and for the periodical cicadas and they
were known to eat uh cicadas it's been
going on for a long time
um and we're just lucky enough to begin
to still keep witnessing it
so with climate change it's possible
that the timing of their emergence might
might change um but hopefully this kind
of
neat phenomenon doesn't change
got it and if climate change where
things get warmer it'll reach 65 degrees
earlier in the year
that could that's another thing that
could fool birds or whoever who's
expecting them
on may 3rd you know whatever is their
their clock time
that they're working on uh okay nageem
keep it coming okay so cameron bishop
asks how do they sustain themselves
during that 17-year period where they're
underground and what impact can we
expect them to have
on the local ecology and wildlife
well i mean they're sustaining
themselves by by feeding on
uh they kind of have so the order had
mipsure
to which they belong um what are the
synaptic what's the name of that order
again say that order
hadn't said
it stands for half wing i guess because
they have an interesting
um aspect to their wing morphology but
anyways they all have these
uh sucking mouth parts that they suck um
they
have sucking mouth parts uh and cicadas
use those sucking mouth parts to kind of
tap into the roots of trees
and then they can suck up this xylem
this this this
this tree uh fluid um and so that's what
that's how they're sustaining themselves
for those 17 years
is just kind of drinking and anyone
who's ever had a liquid diet
um as imagine what you will
for these poor cicadas in their little
excavation drinking lots and lots of
liquid what comes in must come out and
so they actually
you know it's a very sweet sticky
substance uh that then they have to
create into their little excavation uh
and they sit there bathed in their own
kind of liquid gary poop um
that's their life for 17 years that's
what they do that's who they be
and let's make jewelry out of that yes
of course okay
no oh sorry just the adult oh
stupid me is the title of the episode
liquid sugary poop maybe i'm just
throwing it out there
it's a good pancake if there's any punk
crackers out there liquid sugary poop
yeah
i think that ship sailed with the punk
rock era i don't know i don't know
so negan give me some more okay so um
listen jessica you may be
feel a little defensive about this next
question but i promise you ashlynn just
wants to get to the science of it her
question is
what do cicadas do to my knowledge all
animals fit into their own ecological
career even wasps pollinate
do cicadas have an important ecological
purpose or are they just here to fill my
nights of staring at the stars with
music
it ended nicely it started with a little
bit of blended the astro
part of that with the bug part of that i
see what she did
i appreciate that well i mean what do
they do
i think they're i mean like all
organisms they
have this goal of growth maintenance
reproduction
dispersal mating death that's what they
do
right their goal is to get their genes
into next generation but
um even wasps that pollinate it's not
like they're doing it because they
they want to pollinate you know they're
just kind of
um going about those other goals right
which uh
which is growth maintenance reproduction
uh and then eventually they die
they're passing their genes on to the
next generation so cicadas
one benefit that they do have though is
that this incredible i mean they're a
food source
um so they're a food source to many
things including
you know there's pathogens that eat them
there's birds that eat them
there's mammals eat them there's
reptiles need them um humans that eat
them
so i mean in terms of something that
they could put in towards the community
provide nutrition in you know annual
anything that dies can can you know
decompose and and provide nutrition for
it wait wait just i'm not buying it
because
there are birds that are born live out
their lives and die
in between cicada invasions so they
would never know the cicadas so you're
going to say
it's food for animals that they get to
eat once every 17
years well if that's the only time i ate
i'd be
dead so clearly it's extra food for them
yeah so let me ask is the extra food
have an impact on the ecosystem
yeah i mean so that's a good point so
it's not that there's you know a bird
that only eats periodic
periodical cicadas and it goes between
these long stretches of not eating
um certainly not but yeah the extra food
is a boon of energy uh you know that's
every 15 years but the
roots are staggered too we have to
remember so
you know there's a brew that's coming
out this year there'll be a brew that's
coming out in two years and so on
so every few years there's going to be
these emergencies they're not always the
same size because some boots are bigger
than others
but there's these kind of and as you
said there are some places where their
cicadas every year i think in the far
east for example
japan i heard has cicadas and korea
zakat is every year is that correct yeah
we do too i mean even
here in dirty jurors we've got annual
cicadas that come
out and you were you were coming to us
from new jersey right now yes i am
because you were formerly on the faculty
at rutgers and then we stole you from
rutgers university in new brunswick so
they'll get some
some cicadas emerging for sure
actually you know what you know when i
was a graduate student i did my phd at
rutgers in new brunswick
and i just moved here from canada and
they were talking that my graduate
students that were in the lab were
talking about these periodical cicadas
that were coming out and they were going
to drive over and see them in princeton
and i had no idea what they were talking
about because there's a couple
that come up in southern ontario but not
where i lived in canada
i had no idea so it's kind of blows my
mind that the last time route 10 which
is what we're talking about came out
i was uh you know was at that time in
your life yeah first year grad student
and now look so much has
happened since then my goodness cool we
used to do
myspace accounts during the last
exam
cargo pants were very popular
all right so what more do you have in
the game all right cosmic queries mode
here
so um this question sounds like it comes
from elon musk but it actually comes
from michael borger who asked
jessica um have you eaten
cicadas before why yes neil i have
i love what do they taste like
and do they taste like chicken i
definitely did not think they tasted
like chicken but the way i had them
prepared
lovingly you know sauteed in hand and
really taken care of
were just regular annual cicadas and
they tasted very nutty
and they tasted delicious periodicals
are killers i had i didn't
prepared in a very glamorous way so i
try to erase that from
from my mind but this year so help me
i'm going to
make a really good feast with them
they're very nutty if you are allergic
to crustaceans
um you know it's recommended that you
should check before you start eating
them just because some people who have
crustacean allergies
also can have allergies um when they eat
insects
but um it's a great source of protein so
if you're going to mars
get some insects on the menu which is
called entomophagy that's the eating of
insects
um and it's a really good ant and to
entomophagy or entomophagy
that's just i eat insects that's all
that means is that right
and it's a great i mean i don't know
that i would make cicadas as my main
food source probably
if i was trying to grow things quickly i
would grow mealworms or wax worms or
caterpillars or larvae something that
you could like kind of grow very quickly
and have a lot of food for your
for your martian colonists um that's
what i would do
recipes available upon request if it
seems to me if we have the technology
to send humans to mars to colonize it
then
we could send regular food i'm thinking
i'm just thinking
how do you have this whole modern
spaceship oh eat your cicadas
i'm thinking no no no if you can do this
put give me give me the rib eye give me
the
give me the lasagna give me whatever so
that's how i'm thinking i'm just saying
well yeah okay not to not to go in on a
whole entire phagy thing but technically
you can make a pretty great lasagna with
cicadas
in it right i mean as far as your gym
[Music]
i just i don't know do you buy him from
trader joe's like how do you
even i can't um
no i i i i think let's all
i'm i'm gonna make you a nice lasagna
neil we're gonna like we're gonna make
this happen
all right no here's what i'll do jessica
i will promise you
that i will eat
at least one at most three cicadas
um if i prepare it in a pan with some
oil sort of pan fried
i will do that for you okay take it it's
what would you
talk about it didn't happen yeah i would
say photoshop doesn't happen but yes
please
i would i would say take the wings up
because the wings are
not the most fun part to eat but that
she even knows this about it
she removes the wings so she can make
earrings meal
we've already established that you don't
eat them you make them into jewelry
oh all right i will do i will do that
for you
okay thank you as my as my cherished
colleague
i will do that for you and i will give
her a full report and you're writing
again it's got to be
uh tick tock or nothing
i will i will it's for science i will
join in this challenge
by supporting you and watching the tick
tock
that is so sweet thank you that's i'm
here for the show
all right let's get another get some
more questions well phillip dewindt asks
why is it a 17 year old cycle and not a
15-year cycle or 20-year cycle
god i have the same question why it's
such a weird plus 13 and 17 are both
prime numbers mathematically is anything
to that
yeah i think that they do uh think that
the the
the fact that it's a prime number is
significant and they do think that the
13 years actually
were originally 17 years but then
started coming out early and we tend to
see 13-year
uh emergencies more complex the broods
that are 13 years are more common in
southern states
than they are in northern states so um
that's kind of significant but i don't
know
i mean when this when there was
selection on this
you know behavior the theories of
evolutionary um
kind of processes forces yeah that led
us to now
why 17 why 15 why 19
i don't know the answer to that i mean
chris simon like i said the green
gene kritsky there are a few people that
have like focused their whole life on
trying to figure it figure out why
things why these things are periodical
but i don't know if they know the answer
of why 17 and not 15 and why 17 and not
19.
and to follow up an earlier question
just to flesh it out a little more
if we agree and it's expected that
climate change if the
planet gets warmed might have the
cicadas emerge from the ground
sooner in the season because the ground
is warmer
earlier but do you foresee climate
change affecting their cycle
well i think we've already seen a little
taste of it or what
some scientists think that maybe it was
a little taste of it because some of
brutan actually emerged early
um not a lot of them but some of them
emerged early i think it was 2018
um so and they thought that perhaps that
could have been influenced by climate
change
you know that could have changed the
kind of developmental cycles like i said
it goes through they go through these
these molts to instars and it's kind of
controlled with these biochemical
cascades um
and then they emerged early um and it's
uh
you know you lose the benefit of that
satiation strategy
if it's a few scragglers uh that are
emerging rather than
millions and millions of individuals
yeah yeah okay
all right that's what that looks like
and again give me one more question
before we end this segment
okay eric linneman asks are there any
other types of bugs besides cicadas that
hibernate for such long periods of time
and how's the hibernation useful why do
they hibernate in the first place
at all and we don't have time to answer
that see what i did there we got to come
back
after the break and when we come back
we'll find out
is this and are we allowed to even call
it hibernation um
why you know why is that useful at all
to anybody
and i want to know the answer to that
too when we return start cosmic queries
we're back star talk cosmic queries the
cicada edition
just before the cicada invasion i've
gotten again for assad my co-host and
again you're you're
on social media as just your name
far side yeah any g-i-n
f-a-r-s-a-d that's right and can i log
roll really quick that
i'm also in the new adult swim show bird
girl
um on the cartoon network so check that
out on sunday nights
whoa you mean your voices yes my voice
my voice
my face is a green mine taker
but uh i was wondering were you tuned or
is it just a voice for something else
that doesn't look like you
yeah all right well look for that very
good
very good and jessica what cartoon are
you in
i feel like there's not like a huge
demand for insect cartoons although
there should be
that should be for sure because there's
a lot of fertile material
down there so jessica what are your uh
social media handles
uh you can find me on twitter at jessica
l where lab
or on instagram jessica lee williams you
you appended the
the word lab after where jessica wear
lab
yeah jessica l warelab and it's because
there's this amazing singer whose name
is also jessica ware
uh so if you google jessica where you'll
get this british singer who
sings soulful ballads and you won't get
your cicada content that you want or
you're dragging with my content so
i want that dragon ball then it's
jessica
gotta get the insect content okay and on
instagram
it's what jessica lee ware 42. so before
we get back to the questions
uh jessica how many
cicadas can we expect there's going to
be millions about you know one and a
half million
cicadas per acre no no don't know
just what what no it's a good number no
it'll be enough there'll be an acre yeah
so there's i mean there this is the this
is the deal there's millions and
millions of them
um and uh in the places where they're
going to be emerging
you should expect that you could take a
shovel and be able to shovel some of
them up
i won't be able to walk down the street
without smashing
hundreds of them not on purpose well i
mean maybe not in manhattan but
certainly if you were to go to some of
the places where they're going to be
out yeah you're going to see it and they
fly does that mean they'll get in your
i mean how much do they fly versus how
much are they walking around on the
ground
well they're i mean again their goals
are just to make to find a mate
um so they're gonna you mostly will hear
them stop defending them this way
just stop giving them no i'm tired of
hearing you say they're just trying to
make it
just just get straight to the answer
here but you'll see that maybe on the
bark of trees you'll see them
and you'll hear them in the canopy but
you're not going to really see them
flying around
um it's not like they'll be uh you know
clouds of them or anything like that
they'll mostly be in and amongst the
canopy sometimes you'll see them on the
grass of them if you're walking through
a dewy meadow
you might see some uh in the grass but
it'll mostly be
on the barks of trees and in trees and
the ones that are in manhattan are they
dressed better these
drivers are they real type cicadas
they do they go from they they really
like to go up and down looking for sushi
restaurants
and yeah mostly just i knew it
it's the other diet it's they think
there's a juvenile
so she is an adult let's get back to our
questions
nagin you're you're the keeper of the
questions there bring them on
before we left we asked um from eric
linneman are there any other types of
bugs besides cicadas that hibernate for
such a long period of time
how is this hibernation useful and why
do they hibernate in the first place
i love it well yeah jessica it's a good
question but i would say that what
cicadas are doing is probably not
hibernation right because in underground
we're not watching them
right they're underground but they're
actually you know um
not in a hibernation state uh they're
not in torp where they're they're
basically
drinking pooping moving molting
you know that that whole 17 period um
but uh there are other insects certainly
that have long gender this
it's kind of like their generation time
is kind of long that's what we would say
and there are other insects that have
long generation time uh not that i
planted that question just to start
talking about dragonflies again but
dragonflies
have juvenile stages that are in
freshwater and some of them are in
freshwater for
you know five years before emerging as
an adult
and which is a pretty good amount of
time uh termites you know there are some
termite queens that can live for 10
12 13 uh years um
again they're not hibernating they just
have these long kind of
um lifespans so dragonflies and damso
fights uh can also be frozen in solid
ice
which is pretty remarkable you're
calling them um
you're calling it hibernation but in the
pandemic era i would just call that
self-quarantining for 17.
exactly that's what they're doing down
there
wait wait so jessica i i have a
philosophical question
and maybe i think it's deeper than it
actually
is so let me just quickly ask you how
long does the cicada live
after it emerges from the ground uh 46
weeks
okay so its life cycle
is 17 years plus four to six weeks which
means
it's not hibernating waiting to do
something else in its life
that is its life yeah that is deep
that's deep i mean what is life right
what is time what is life right that is
it's life
it's sucking on plant roots and peeing
and pooping
that is its life and then its
death throw is sunlight
and people screaming as they run away
from them except for jessica
who wants to make jewelry out of them
and then they die
yeah i mean much like so say it's the
same is true for these dragonflights
that are five years in fresh water
they come out it's one hot summer you
know that's what these cicadas have they
got this really short window to find a
mate uh get that
job done of passing on their jeans but
that's like a
that's like a bookend or a footnote even
though it's you know probably
just a footnote to the whole life that
they're leading yeah even though it's
probably the most important part
they do you really have to love the
process if you're a cicada you can't be
destination oriented because the desert
you know you get there and then you're
gone it's a marathon not a sprint you
really have to love the process i love
the journey
all right keep them coming again all
right we have um
from uh bobby regan uh sorry
from bobby reagan we have a question
that kind of merges um
your both of your interests uh he asks
can anything like their hibernation be
recreated on a human scale for deep
space travel
well again they're not hibernating so
could we go into deep space
and drink syrupy sugary drinks
and just poop constantly yeah we could
do that i mean i could do that
i don't think that would be hard to do
we would have to change nothing
i'm going to change almost nothing about
my day-to-day life i would just be doing
it in space
um but no no no i think the way jessica
i think the
a a way to do this i think the way to do
this is
you prolong the time we are infants
in a long space journey because why
waste time in space as an adult
when you want to have the fully
developed adult brain for when you land
and you want to investigate so the so
the infant would be
just pooping and sucking right yeah
so so you increase that period of time
in the human developmental cycle to be
17 20 years and then you just put them
in and just poop and pee and that's it
and then towards the end you bring them
out and then they grow into adults
wow neil basically you're saying that my
baby has been prepping for space travel
this whole time
no idea wow i've got this figured out
how old how old is your baby
so she's more of a toddler these days
yeah no toddler yeah yeah no more
diapers
really she's she's uh she's pooping in a
potty and if it was liquid and sugary i
mean i'd be getting in there
it's just it is
[Music]
i need you on the rails not off the
rails with jessica okay
please stay with me here you start
talking about insect poop it just goes
you accelerate towards this is the
mental state we're in now
it's all poop talk for the rest i know
okay well i read that book you know to
our kids every every
everybody poops i think is it originally
an italian kids story
everybody poops it just shows all the
animals everybody pooping and so the
your kids will learn that it's a very
natural thing for all things that are
alive
so yeah it does make sense that liquid
feeders would have like with you know
very liquidy poop like
which are suckers that's what they have
there it is all right all right nagin
keep it coming here we go matthew ritter
asks cicadas are known for being very
loud to us humans
how good is the cicadas sense of hearing
are they deafening to each other and
drown out all the sources
of auditory information in their own
environment i like that yes
i like that that's a good question i
mean so you would expect that selection
should act
on females to be able to hear the calls
of
males um yeah just
just as males have been selected to make
the calls
long and loud so that the leg the the so
different species of cicadas are out at
any given time right and so
um the calls that males make are
actually species-specific songs
um but also like but so only the males
make the calls
the females don't make the calls the
males are making the calls the females
kind of
kind of move their wings around a little
bit to attract mates but as far as i
understand it but
it's the call that's really the the
mating okay now i have to know just i
gotta butt in here
okay so when i eat my three cicadas
should i eat the ones that are making
noise or the ones that aren't just which
ones taste better
surely you know the answer to that
question well i mean so the males that
call the longest and the loudest
um are the ones that are going to get
the most mates so maybe you want like
maybe is that like a prime
rib like like a like a grade a
to the genus the species if i ate the
most successful
so i should eat the unsuccessful ones
yeah i don't want to interfere with it
so they've made it and then
as soon as that's done and the female
goes off to do her job of laying those
eggs
you get that male you eat it okay that
could be your solution
yeah so that so after the fact right the
males are making these long calls the
females are
are listening for the loudest and
longest calls
and they tend to call in the hottest
times of the day which can be kind of
energetically expensive
uh so these are all cues these are all
signals that females can use
that she is um you know to choose a mate
that is going to be
uh uh able to make it so that her her
sons would have the same traits so they
would be likely to be set
to selected too that's called the sexy
sense hypothesis uh but then also you
know
it's just you know she wants to get as
many of her genes into the next
generation as possible
um you know that's the selection that's
how selection is is acting
mm-hmm damn okay release the game and
run it short on time
okay let's let's see if we get a light
and a quick lightning round in here
jessica one sentence answers all right
legend go um uh my daughter trinity asks
if the cicadas
cycle have been impacted by human
settlement
for sure we build over there uh we pay
parents we have a parking lot uh so we
build over their habitat constantly
so okay all right so those if you happen
to be under the house they got built you
ain't never coming out
yeah i mean especially if they cut down
the tree which is your food source right
if you're yeah that's the answer
yeah all right dude you died uh in in in
while you're developing
that that would be sad that's a sad
story
you got me you got me empathizing with
them now jessica what's
why so you what i don't want to
empathize with these ugly bugs okay
all right with these beady eyes like on
each corner okay negan go
well uh stefan somers um wants just a
specific recipe you mentioned uh
sauteing them in oil are you adding any
herbs in there what's going on
i might add a little i might add a
little salt yes i have
had exotic foods prepared for me in the
past i've had
a fried tarantula and it tasted like
crab
i maybe we shouldn't be surprised um and
i've had um what else i had uh beetles
as well there was sauteed no no no no so
they weren't beetles they were uh
crickets
oh yeah sauteed crickets and they were
sort of crunchy and made like a little
snack you know like crunchy snacks as we
like here in america
so i'm going to try to turn it into a
crunchy snack and then i'll and i'll
uh get back okay keep it going next one
we got a
very interesting question from nathan
kane who says would a flamethrower be a
sufficient way to eliminate the cicadas
if one in every five
humans on the east coast has one
yes yes throwing
cicadas with flamethrowers right i'd say
that you take 10 minutes in the timeout
chair and really reevaluate your life
because if you've got it and you're
putting in any of those cicadas
then neil's going to give me your number
and i'm going to go there and i'm going
to feed with you to make some jewelry
instead
yeah you could kill them on fire but why
would you
why would you why would you yeah
or maybe no no here here it is i'm just
going to cook them so i can eat them
see there you go there it is and we
actually have to call it quits there but
i want to add jessica there was a movie
where insects were a very important part
of one of the characters
and it was in men in black men in black
insects were very there was one this guy
who was just this pile of insects
and i think he was oh do you know his
name
i'd forgotten yeah
edgar excuse me i wasn't on a first name
basis with this character
this alien character uh so yeah so
insects plus
uh the movie them with the back from the
60s or 50s with the big ants insects
have made their rounds
in pop culture so i think you're in a
good place for us to reach for you again
when we want to get to the bottom of
what insects are up to so
jessica it's been a delight to have you
on it's the first time we've had a
sustained conversation
you being new to the museum i hope to
see more of you there we can um
chill out and get you on more uh on more
star talk episodes
uh then nagin always good to have you so
great to be here neil
and i'm waiting for my next invitation
on your podcast on which i've only been
invited once
okay i i've been on the daily show
14 times okay well neil they have
different standards
[Laughter]
all right guys we're going to call it
quits there thanks for thanks for making
this work this has been star talk cosmic
queries
the cicadas are coming edition i'm neil
degrass tyson
bidding you to keep looking up
you